when defining York market segments you
want to make sure you don't define
segments that are too narrow
ask yourself isn't it offering really
different from one segment to another it
can be different by price or by features
and if you realize that you offer the
same to two different segments maybe you
should define them as one bigger segment
for startups it's crucial to measure not
only the quantity of the potential
segments but its quality a quality
segment will help you engage users
quickly learn from them and iterate on
your product make sure you choose a
segment that is accessible for you your
university or group of friends or your
neighborhood if relevant choose a
segment with the shortest sale cycle so
you don't wait too long between the time
your customers is exposed to the product
until it can show value you can do that
by choosing the segment that will
consume a more simple product or the
segment that will be willing to pay
maybe less but buy your product more
quickly if you have a b2b product you
better start with the smaller companies
as your customers and reach out directly
to the decision-maker rather than going
through a lengthy process of a big
company in addition try to find a
segment that is less crowded so you have
no or few competitors for example the
messaging company slack found great
opportunity in their enterprise segment
with very little competition they
realize their value was to focus
specifically on tech teams and small
companies and startups that the work
quickly and needed to communicate
quickly with tech features integrated in
their product had they wanted to focus
on consumers rather than other fries
they would have been faced with a great
deal of good competition like what
happened we chat